a warm welcome to you please mr
president
i would like to focus on four areas
where g7 cooperation
is particularly needed first global
health
sudden foreign policy third climate
change
and fourth corporate taxation first
double health
we must make sure that the world is
being vaccinated as quickly as possible
and the eu is at the forefront of
ensuring
global equitable access to vaccines
especially
to developing countries and the g7 as a
whole
are major producers of vaccines the eu
is largest export of october 19 vaccines
to the world
so far we have exported more than 270
million doses
and we are top contributor to the covert
facility
with over 2.8 billion euros we will
donate
at least 100 million dollars by the end
of the year
we must also strengthen manufacturing
capacities around the world
and so we'll invest 1 billion euros to
boost
vaccine production in africa we are also
ready to work
in latin america and to develop projects
in this part of the world
the question of intellectual property
rights will likely be raised
in this context a patent river might
sound good but it's
no silver bullet the trips agreement
already offers flexibility
and we want to focus on concrete
proposals
such as promoting promote involuntary
licensing
and knowledge transfers and patent
pooling
on mutually agreed terms g7 leaders
will also discuss how best to prepare
for future pain damage
building on the wrong declaration and
this idea
of a treaty is now supported by
more than 60 countries the world's
health assembly has just decided two
weeks ago
to start the meaning such a treaty
it has taken the unprecedented decision
to convene
a special world health assembly in
november to legally decide on the launch
on former negotiations
second important topic foreign policy
the g7
together with four guest countries
australia india south africa and south
korea
will reaffirm our belief in open
societies
multilateralism and democratic values
these values underpin the actions we
take the policies we develop
and the partnerships we build in this
context
russia will be one of the main topics g7
partners
share similar views on russia's
disruptive activities
the eu condemns illegal provocative
and disruptive russian activities
against the eu
its member states and beyond i stress
this to president putin in a phone call
this week
on the conflict in the eastern ukraine i
will repeat that we do not see
russia as a mediator but as a party to
the conflict
we do not and will not recognize
russia's
of crimea at last month's european
council
eu leaders took rapid action against the
authorities in belarus
for the fourth landing of a flight this
was
an attack on democracy the media and
freedom of speech
but also civilian aviation safety
and this robust action has set the tone
for the international response to this
incident
we once again call on the belarus
authorities
to immediately release rahman
prateshevich
and sophia cepeda and all political
prisoners
at the summit we will of course also
discuss
our complex relationship with china the
eu's approach
is clear china is a partner
a competitor and a potential systemic
rival
we must strike the right balance for our
best interest
between engagement and standing firmly
by our values we have to work with china
to address global challenges
like climate change or regional issues
like afghanistan
or the iran nuclear deals and economic
relations with china
are important for economic recovery at
the same time
we will defend ourselves against
practices
that pose security risks distort the
level playing field
or are incompatible with our values
we'll continue to stand up to defend
human rights
and the rule of law in qin chang hong
kong
and elsewhere
[Music]
foreign
um indeed we we are very much looking
forward
uh to have this g7 again finally
um to have the g7 countries like-minded
countries
that share the same values that their
the same interest and that share also
the same world view so it's good that
the us are back and it's good that the
g7 by this is back
again too we have a very broad agenda
these three days are really packed so
i want to focus on some of the topics
the economic
impact of the crisis we'll look at that
we will of course also look at the
international environment the
rules-based system
will look at the education the global
education status health of course and
climate
so on the economy at the beginning we
will discuss as g7
how the state of play is and how we view
the progress
in our economies and what uh the best
approach could be and
we we haven't forgotten you all remember
a year ago
how threatening this health crisis was
and still is
for our um for our economies
i mean it it had the potential to turn
into a massive economic crisis
interestingly if we look at the european
union
we tackled the economic fallout from the
pandemic from this crisis
much better than for example compared to
the last big crisis the financial crisis
in 2008
and why was this this the case it was
the case because
the european union after the last big
crisis
drew the necessary conclusions from uh
this crisis and developed effective
tools
so when this pandemic and this economic
crisis
uh hit we were able to establish a very
fast a
diagnosis of the economic
fallout we came very fast to a consensus
on the
necessary remedial action
and then we could act forcefully on old
fronts
if you look at the member states we
enabled the member states to act swiftly
for example through the general escape
clause through the temporary
stated framework and for complete the
flexibilization of the eu budget
and we enable the european level to act
forcefully and swiftly at the beginning
with sure
and now with next generation eu
and we will have a look at the g7
overall interestingly if you take
together the whole
financial fiscal support in the european
union if you look at the plans or what
has been done in 2020
21 and 22
there is an amount to fiscal support
equivalent to 18
of gdp in europe
and this is completely at par on par
with the united states
if you look at the plans of the united
states that sum
up to 20 percent of gdp
fiscal support in 2020 21
and 22. we will certainly discuss
that topic the second important factor
why we come back better
is that when the crisis hit
the european union had just put in place
its plans concerning our priorities
the european green deal the digitization
and resilience
and the crisis proved us right in the
priorities we had set
thus our spending goes into investment
for green and digital transition and
into resilience
and the plan was there the roadmap was
there and we could immediately act
but of course we are also um open
economies
so our prosperity therefore will depend
on our partners response
to the crisis so i'm very much looking
forward to the g7
confirming that there will be continued
parallelism
of our approaches and particular in
maintaining fiscal support
now to the second topic of course the g7
will also look at the risks
and threats to the recovery by the
international environment we have
and here two points stand out first of
all the economic resilience
domestically there too we have developed
over the past month our tools
to guard ourselves against risks so
to defend an open society to have
economic exchange but not at any
costs for example if you look at our
tool of the 5g toolbox or the dual
use exports controls but also
the fdi screening we have now in place
our proposal for
to block distortive foreign subsidies
and the second topic of course will be
that we will guard
the respect for our values we want
cooperation
we want the lively exchange but on the
basis
of democratic values and on the basis of
fundamental rights and for that too we
have developed over the last month
our tools for example the global human
rights sanctions regime
or our forthcoming proposal for an
anti-coercion instrument
and of course the whole tool set of
human-centric approach to the digital
world you know it it's the digital
services act the digital markets act and
the regulation
on ai that is human centered
we know that china and russia are
particular sources of concern
in those areas and therefore the g
seven are finally again
united and determined to protect
and to promote our values
the next topic we will look at is the
best way
to defend our values and to promote our
values and that
is to reinforce a strong and rules-based
multilateralism
and with the return of the united states
to a global arena
we are very much looking forward to the
g7 backing
effective action to strengthen
multilateralism
we need effective wto rules making
including a
g7 commitment to help reform the wto
and the entire rules based system
and we also need to strengthen our g7
partnership
with developing countries for example on
connectivity
as we have already agreed for example
with japan and india
here two coordination with g7 partners
can help to maximize the benefits
of our investments from an economic but
also sustainability and political point
of view
but even more important than the
investments
in infrastructure they are important but
more important are also the investments
in people and here let me have a look
at the g7 emphasis on education for
development
covet has led to one of the worst
education crisis in history
for children around the world and we
know
that especially girls and young women
are at risk
because of the pandemic around 11
million girls from
pre-primary to secondary school are at
risk
of not returning to school with all the
consequences behind that
for their lives and this is a bitter
legacy of covet
and we must join forces to secure the
perspectives
of young girls and women and therefore
the european union strongly subscribes
to the objective of 40 million more
girls in schools by 2026
and 20 million more girls reading by age
10
or end of primary school and for that we
need
sustainable financing we have for that
the global partnership
for education and this should be
underpinned
by as i said sustainable financing so i
am glad
to announce that the european commission
will
increase its contribution by 32 percent
last mff we contributed 68 million euro
per year
that was over the period of seven years
then 475 million
now we will raise this contribution to
100 million per year that is
an overall of 700 million euro over the
period
of seven years our mff
but we will also not forget the most
urgent
of necessity and that is the fight
against hunger
here as well the european commission
will step up to the plate
by providing 250 million euro of new
humanitarian funding
targeted targeting acute food insecurity
in the sahel east africa central african
republic
sudan and ethiopia
turning towards the topic of health we
do
subscribe the g7 aim to end the pandemic
by 2022 by stepping up the global
vaccination
the european union has from the
beginning contributed massively to this
you know the figures
since vaccines became available the
european union has acted
not only that we at the very beginning
with the friends
created act accelerator and covax but we
pledged heavily for it but we also have
from the beginning ensured
that the domestic vaccination goes hand
in hand
with exports to the rest of the world
and we have good news
today in europe more than 50 percent
of the adult population have received at
least one shot
and even better today 100 million
europeans are
fully vaccinated we achieved that
whilst never stopping export
from the 700 million doses that have
been produced in the european union
since
last december roughly 350 million doses
have been
exported to over 90 countries
and a few weeks ago i invited others to
also participate and practice
openness and i'm very glad to see that
the draft communique
reflects this now and it is very
encouraging
to listen to the potential announcements
of the united states
beyond 2022 it is not just about sharing
vaccines but it will be also about
developing manufacturing capacity
in africa you know that team europe
announced indeed 1 billion of support to
develop manufacturing capacity
in africa here is important not only to
bring the mrna technology
for vaccines against kovic to africa
but also to bring this technology to
africa because it is very promising
for other infectious disease for example
like tuberculosis
or for example malaria so there's an
enormous good
case to make sure that there are
different
manufacturing hubs being developed in
different regions of
africa finally on climate
we committed to limit temperature
increase
to 1.5 degrees celsius
i welcome that the g7 are also aiming in
this
direction but i want to be very clear
even a world
that is just 1.5 degrees celsius
warmer than today will be much worse
than today and therefore adaptation
policies
must be a central element of our climate
policies
in the european union but also of course
with our
partner countries we acknowledge their
specific needs
and in fact the european union already
spends about
half of its development finance
on projects that support at the same
time development
and adaptation to climate change
but on top of this as you know we have
this
climate financing so we support the g7
objective of 100 billion
dollar per year on climate financing
team europe has consistently contributed
25 billion
dollar to the over the last three years
and we will come up
with a renewed commitment for glasgow
cop
26 on that topic too that was a lot
thanks for your patience thank you madam
president we have
quite a few journalists joining us and
asking questions i'll start first
with a question from the uk uh laura
kunzberg
from the bbc laura you have the floor
good morning
thank you good morning everyone from
cornwall um the northern ireland
protocol
will no doubt be one of the subjects of
conversation here
um madame president what will you say to
boris johnson
on this subject and while the eu's been
very critical
of what the uk is doing can you honestly
say that you are keeping your promise to
cause the minimum
possible disruption to the people of
northern ireland
absolutely absolutely the european union
is determined
to make the protocol work for the
benefit of
everyone in northern ireland and we have
bent
over backwards for years to find
solution on that
um we agree with the we agreed with the
united kingdom that the protocol was
the only solution ensuring the absence
of a hard border of northern ireland
we've been really
debating that since years and we found
the one and only
solution now we have a treaty on that
the withdrawal agreement it has been
signed by both
sides pakta soon servanda it is
important that we now
implement the protocol we have shown
flexibility
we will show flexibility but the
protocol the withdrawal agreement
has to be implemented completely
and these are often technical things
that have to be done for example build
up the necessary infrastructure
or give the european union the access to
the i.t
as was agreed that is important so
we still see fundamental gaps in the
implementation of the protocol
and unilateral measures de-applying some
provisions
of the protocol we will discuss that in
a trilateral meeting
in cornwall together we are determined
to do everything to keep peace and
stability on the island of ireland
it is important that there is
deep respect for the protocol that we
protected
and for that we have the withdrawal
agreement it's a good agreement
all sides signed this agreement
now it has to be implemented
next question is for john chalmers
actually from
reuters here in brussels
john yes uh
good morning john johnson reuters thank
you for the opportunity to ask a
question
i'll keep it on the same subject um for
the president of the european council
what will your message be in cornwall to
prime minister johnson
on the question of the northern ireland
protocol impasse
and do you agree with the u.s president
joe biden that the uk's approach to the
issue
is imperiling peace in northern ireland
and if i could just add a question if i
may for the president of the commission
um vice president sefkovic spoke of
consequences for the uk
if it continues on its current path what
might these be
and could they include tariffs and
quotas thank you
the first point i would like to to fully
confirm what has been said by
ursula we are exactly on the same page
and we will give
exactly the same message i would like
also to insist on the fact that
that member states uh in europe uh they
are expressing more and more worries
about the current situation
because indeed it's fundamental it's
paramount
to implement what we have decided this
is a question
of a rule of law which is an important
value that we share
in in common and the good fight the
agreement is of
course a priority we want to make sure
that
this good friday agreement will be fully
implemented and it's very important for
the european union
to implement what you have decided to be
a loyal partner
but at the same time we will use all the
tools we have
in order to make sure that we defend our
interests that we protect the integrity
of the single
market and that we guarantee the level
playing field
yes to answer your question um the good
part
part about an agreement a signed treaty
is
that both sides signed up to also
a dispute settlement mechanism and
to remedial measures that can be taken
so
there are no unilateral actions but
there is an agreed
dispute settlement mechanism with
different steps
in our tca and for the withdrawal
agreement
and therefore it is possible i'm
deeply convinced that the uk can
work on implementing the withdrawal
agreement
but if not it is possible to move
forward
with the within the agreed frame
to have remedial measures and dispute
settlement
mechanism the situation we should not
forget
came because of brexit and we
all agree that we do everything
that there will be no hard border
between ireland and northern ireland but
we also have to
protect the single market the uk
is a third country outside the single
market
and therefore with the withdrawal
agreement and its mechanism
we were able to square the circle
by making sure there is no hard border
but we still will have in a different
manner
um controls about goods coming from a
third country from the uk
to the single market and this
agreement has now to be put in place
it's about implementing what has been
agreed
once again often the detail the devil is
in the detail
so therefore we showed and we will show
flexibility
on specific topics but the overall frame
is set and it has to be implemented now
thank you next topic i believe is
coming from the south china morning post
finbar birmingham finbar can you hear us
i can good morning thank you for your
time
um my question is about the
reports that the european union will
join calls for an investigation
into the origins of the coronavirus um
can the presidents confirm whether this
is the case
whether this has been relayed or will be
relayed directly to china and what sort
of reaction you're hoping to get from
beijing
um if you're joining uh the chorus
for this thank you very much
we we are very clear we think that uh we
need full transparency in order to learn
the lessons and that's why we support
all the efforts in order to make the
clarity
uh the world has the right to know
exactly what happened
in order to be able to learn the lessons
and indeed we will support
all the efforts in order to make the
transparency
and to know the truth i can only
underline that it is of utmost
importance that we learn about the
origin of the coronavirus
for the introduction i've been speaking
about the lessons learned of the
european union or the lessons drawn
from the experience of the financial
crisis
and out of this experience we did a good
analysis and then we develop tools
so today in the health crisis we were
faster
the same has to happen here there is
this horrible pandemic a global pandemic
we have to know where it did come from
in order
to draw the right lessons and to develop
the right
tools to make sure that this will never
happen again
and therefore the investigators need
complete access
to whatever is necessary to really find
the source
of this pandemic and depending of that
we have to draw conclusions and there's
a wide scope
of different options that are being
investigated right now
therefore it shows it's important that
we pin down to the one
the one picture that is there for
the start of the pandemic because
for that the investigation teams really
need access to the information and to
the sites
next question is for vince vince
chadwick from devex
vince good morning good morning thanks
baron um
for president vanderlian i wanted um to
ask about ethiopia
um you have frozen budget support
from the commission but the eu member
states have not
and i wanted to ask whether that doesn't
undermine your position on on this
conflict and in particular what your
plans are for the
2021-2027 programming period which is
currently being
considered um and for president michel
on ethiopia again
you said that um you were looking to the
consequences that these actions deserve
when it comes to the
tigray conflict what are those
consequences that you're considering
please
thank the situation
is uh really really concerning
in ethiopia and tigre and therefore
it is important to act and
to give a wake-up call to all
stakeholders
that we really have to focus on that
region to prevent
the worst so what is going on there
is so worrisome that it was for the
european
uh commission important not to do go on
with
the normal procedures but really flag
and mark
that we have to stand up that we have to
care and that we have to be there and
present
um to to prevent a worsening of a
already very very difficult and
concerning situation
i'll take a last question from sam
fleming from the financial times
good morning good morning thanks very
much thank you for taking my question
uh the questions on uh corporate tax um
the g7 accord amongst finance ministers
involves a withdrawal of unilateral
measures and dsts
i wonder does that mean if there is an
oec deal what oecd
deal will the eu plan to withdraw its
planned uh
eu digital levy or do you see the
digital levy as compatible
with an oecd accord on pillar one and
pillar two
and an associated question clearly there
are concerns among eu member states
about this we're hearing
from hungary poland and ireland amongst
them do you see a realistic chance
of pillar one and pillar two being
implemented in the european union
without any enabling directives being
ultimately vetoed and the question is to
both presidents thank you
so
yes so indeed we welcome
the results of the g7 finance minister
concerning
a minimum tax it is
very positive this step forward but of
course we know that now it has to be
brought to g20 and oecd
and progress but we support it what your
question is uh concerned
on the digital levy and
the proposal uh to have the 100th most
wealthy uh companies or most successful
companies
with a specific levy those two are
not conflicting they are more
complementary
because in the development of our
digital levy we're making
sure that this is non-discriminatory
and that there will be no double
taxation
and we are in very close contact with
the relevant stakeholders
this will certainly also be a topic we
will discuss
at our eu us summit so
it is important to move forward is it it
is important
um to we we support very much the
proposal that is on the table
and as i said we make sure that our
digital levy
is uh non-discriminatory and moves
forward too we will see in the very end
um if there is a broader
solution in a large context like the
oecd countries
it's always our favorite
thank you madam president and mr
president we'll have an
eu coordination meeting tomorrow um or
the day after actually in
on friday because it starts at 3 p.m
local time
so we'll keep you updated on our web
page as well
thank you for joining us this morning
and see you soon
[Music]
you